say goodbye to your burger billionaire
climate crusader bill gates says we need
to ditch beef to fight global warming
quote he said
i do think all rich countries should
move to 100
synthetic beef you can get used to the
taste difference
and the claim is they're going to make
it taste even better
over time but there might be a big
conflict of interest here gates
reportedly has invested
in plant-based impossible foods and
beyond meat so dana people who warned
they were coming after our cheeseburgers
and our steaks were made fun of and
called conspiracy theories
theorists and here we are yeah well look
if
he wants to put his money where his
mouth is and support that industry you
know go for it maybe that it will work
for some people but
um his whole book is about his concern
about an existential crisis from climate
change that's one of the reasons he's
talking about this beef issue
do you remember when aoc put out the
green new deal and it said that they
were going to do the very same thing and
it was
it was mocked relentlessly and then they
said well it was just a draft it was
never actually in the bill like no this
is what they believe this is the plan
this is what they're going to do i just
think that um on
as we head into the fourth night of
people in texas millions of them
freezing having to figure out a way to
boil water because the water isn't safe
but they don't have any power
in which to boil the water and a lot of
them are also raising cattle
it is a complete tragedy and mr gates he
is self-admittedly a little socially
awkward
needs to learn how to read the room a
little bit better
greg you're an avid meat eater are you
going to eat fake meat
i'm definitely up for trying uh because
i do have moral issues with eating meat
basically we are eating earthlings so
and so that fact is based on a hierarchy
right we are on top
and we eat everything on bottom if
you're good with that which i am
fine but then you have to eliminate the
idea of sentience that these animals are
conscious beings
and possibly it could happen to you in
let's say in a million years
some other being could come out of the
earth and be have an iq
of a thousand and decide that we're
gonna be their fuel
and then we become animals to them so i
do have i do think about it
probably too much but i am having a
steak tonight so that makes me an
incredible hypocrite
and what did you have last night
well the robots are going to eat us
first they'll be here before we know it
yes well that's what greg tells me
uh you know i mean i think bill gates is
a
is a smart rich guy but he's not the
president
and he's not a governor he's a private
citizen and i don't think any
state government and i don't think the
federal government has any interest in
taking away
anybody's burger or stake uh you know i
think that there's just big concern
about climate change you look at what's
going on down in texas
you know like a once in a century kind
of climate catastrophe down there with
the freeze
and i think you understand why people
are talking the biden administration
about a climate change proposal in
congress
but it really is about from their
perspective change
necessary change job product job
producing change in terms of
doing things like infrastructure
broadband
building highways that can cope with the
coming of electric cars
doing more in terms of our structure to
deal with
energy and improve our electric grids
again to help texas
jesse well just because you're rich
doesn't mean you're right
history's filled with very wealthy men
with horrible ideas trying to
help the masses just because he has an
expertise in one area
doesn't transfer that to another area
getting rid of fossil fuels
and meat those are dangerous radical
ideas and he should be called out for
that
just like anybody that doesn't have that
kind of money
he's also a hypocrite which we don't
have time to talk about but up next